E aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês já estou aqui no carro
para ir fazer outro show Eu já falei
gente é todo show de show e é isso aí
não tem o que fazer mas eu dei um
rolezinho e tenho vários vídeos
atrasados mas onde eu vou sempre ter
alguém filmando Então eu vi o meu
rolezinho e eu quero só mostrar ele para
vocês aqui para vocês curtir a vibe e
ver o conhecendo pessoas que eu tinha
muita vontade de conhecer se você gostar
de estar junto comigo nesse
acontecimento neste momento clica aí no
like e comenta aí embaixo que que você
achou interessante Nossa não sei gente
eu quis dizer
[Risadas]
[Música]
é só realmente é como a gente tava
falando é fake nela perfeição vai
fazendo uma E fazendo mais corrigindo os
erros corrigindo dizendo você assistindo
tem que ter senso de saber da empresa se
vê na tela não fala nada não mas isso aí
que eu falei tem que falar isso quando
eu falar a próxima vez fala tem que se
tem automático também pode crer e você
rapaz engolir o livro desse cabo aqui
todinho se eu for olhar aí no meu
celular é isso aí nós aí depois se não
fingindo que ela tá funcionando não só
falando alto
[Música]
o Bob aí
se matando de rir ó
sanduíche engoliu guaraná mesmo homem
falou da fala e nunca nunca
vai acreditar sempre sempre acreditar no
lugar de cima ele que comanda manda um
salve a do strep um manda o strep também
viu meu filho
tamo junto aí ó oie oie
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Ixi ele já entrou assim então ai ai ai
agora Manoel
[Música]
urso
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí primeira vez de Fortaleza tudo bem
Beleza não primeira vez não mas primeira
vez te vendo você tá ligado
meu Deus existe meu nome eu quero nem
acredito fechou hoje tá ligado fechou
hoje aí tô aqui mas deu certo tá bem no
dia do teu show aqui porque o problema
para nós artista se encontrar e a data
de show né tá entendendo
eu não consigo [ __ ] que pariu né
mas aí na moral se eu te conhecer fala
ok
já na praia moleque é mineiro nós vai
pular no mar ali de roupa mesmo [ __ ]
tá ligado
de cara tatuada mano que que é isso é
massa né encontrar a nossa família
enquanto você coloca lá você olha no
espelho e fala assim Nunca mais
só colete
[Música]
a idade que nós estamos nós continua
fazendo quando a gente vai 46 não tem
mais lugar velho vai ter
nós tivemos que a gente vai ser aquele
tipo de tatuagem não vou ficar renovando
ela no caso né agora tem tudo errado com
a minha vou bater lá
aqui
[Música]
Qual câmera eu olho meu Deus do céu
do nada
ele vai tocar aqui
[Aplausos]
tu vai tocar
tu entra
Vado
é o melhor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
estou preparado
Mas é isso não esquece quando acabar o
vídeo deixa o like por aqui não para
Europa se você quiser me acompanhar é só
deixar o like para ver se você tá
gostando para poder levar esta
câmerazinha aqui comigo esse trambolho
aqui pesa viu é nós